[Musik]
sie finden jahre lang keine arbeit und
fallen in ein tiefes loch
[Musik]
sie landen im abseits js der grund durch
die analysten und beginnen zu zweifeln
mit der qualifikation
der druck wächst
für mich ist sie die letzte chance
[Musik]
sie geben nicht auf passiert das wohnen
garten im rat bleibt hat dass ich so
beschriebene gefühl sehr kämpfen sich
minijobs und sie gewinnen wieder
anerkennung
[Musik]
dort warten gar den schritt in eine neue
ausbildung
[Musik]
vier menschen und ihr kampf um arbeit
und einen platz in der gesellschaft
[Musik]
andreas knoche 59 jahre alt arbeitslos
seit drei jahren
er ist ingenieur elektrotechnik mit
einem nachdiplomstudium als
betriebswirtschafter und hat
jahrzehntelang in führungspositionen
gearbeitet
mehrheitlich im ausland bisher entlassen
wurde
es gibt es nicht und es gibt weniger
kurth gott sei dank sie die wendige
gurte nicht so häufig ob die jetzt und
dass sie so hüttner so dass sie immer
noch frage was eine frau gebracht dass
es mehr recht hat oder was halt ich ein
anderes machen oder hat sich samuel
merke dass sie die richtigkeit dieser
tag gekommen
und da kommen sicher gewesen mit dem
muss man gut ist es aber wichtig dass
man die strukturen tag dort festhalten
etwas meint tanja mit mit stageco
führungspersonal 42 das war ich komplett
falsch ich muss leider ist meine größte
stärke bietet der körper in st aber im
moment ist natürlich schon das ist aber
es ist kein platz mehr
wobei auch viele 2 1 christoph sich
e-mails die andere
alfred waser 58 jahre alt auf
stellensuche seit vier jahren
sozialhilfebezüger wasser lebt in einer
ein zimmer wohnung mit gemeinschafts
benutzung von küche und bad in wohlen
kanton aargau eigentlich eine unterkunft
für kurzaufenthalte wasser ist ebenfalls
elektroingenieur htl und
wirtschaftsingenieur mit ehemals
glänzender karrieren
ich bin mir bewusst dass mit zunehmendem
alter schwieriger wird noch ein soziales
beliefere tisch dass das habe ich so
nicht erwartet dass ich das dass ich
normal bürger zu wenig oder gar nicht
bekommt sehr geehrter herr wasser vielen
dank für ihre bewerbung und das
interesse an unserem unternehmen das
virus erhalten haben welche noch besser
unserem profil entsprechen
für die oben erwähnte stelle haben wir
eine sehr große anzahl von bewerbungen
erhalten besten dank für ihre bewerbung
bei uns ihre unterlagen welches ins
freundlicherweise zur verfügung gestellt
haben werden hier
bei uns im system löschen es tut uns
leid wir bitten um ihr verständnis und
wünschen ihnen für die zukunft beruflich
und privat alles gute was er arbeitete
in seiner letzten anstellung am
paul-scherrer-institut zuvor bei
bombardier alles lief glatt bis er vor
sechs jahren den schritt in die
selbstständigkeit wagte und scheiterte
darauf erlebte vase den sozialen abstieg
das heißt dass mm prozent das heißt dass
sie von sozialhilfe abhängig bin und das
auf nicht absehbare zeit mal absehbar
bevor die sozialhilfe übernimmt müssen
die betroffenen alles verkaufen was sie
nicht unmittelbar zum leben brauchen
das kann ein eigenheim seien wertpapiere
oder das auto heute lebt waser von 986
franken im monat zusätzlich zahlt das
sozialamt miete und krankenkasse den
alfred bauer verlor alles auch die
beziehung ging in die brüche in seinem
haus in bellach ist andreas knüttel
selten allein
er hat zwei erwachsene kinder tochter
tamara kommt häufig zu besuch
als ihr vater arbeitslos wurde wohnte
sie als studentin noch im elternhaus
also was man viel gefordert haben wenige
gemacht hat was die auslauf der
haupteigner standard wie ist das für
mich
doch auch mit einem studium ab 1920
jener könig behält nur unterstützen
mini unterstützt agno ich hatte auch
nicht immer da so vertreterin einfach
ist das auch sehr negativ behaftet wie
ihr bruder matthias ging sie zunächst
davon aus dass der vater rasch wieder
arbeit findet beide tauschten sich zwei
jahre bekam knuchel arbeitslosengeld
dann wurde er aus gesteuert er lebt
heute ohne einkommen und bezieht keine
sozialhilfe sonst müsste er das haus
verkaufen
matthias kann als medizinstudent nichts
beisteuern
aber die familie hält zusammen
langzeitarbeitslosigkeit eine enorme
belastung für die betroffenen und ihre
angehörigen
heidi knuchel hat ihre stelle von 60 auf
100 prozent aufgestockt um den
einkommensverlust ihres mannes
aufzufangen
sie möchte sich in diesem film nicht
äußern
[Musik]
menschen über 50 sind zwar weniger
häufig arbeitslos als jüngere
wenn sie aber den job verlieren sind die
folgen gravierend die arbeitslosigkeit
dauert länger zum teil bis zur
pensionierung roth stadelmann 61
ehemalige postangestellte seit zehn
jahren arbeitslos plötzlich hatte sie
unendlich viel zeit
soll ich mich beschäftigt
in diesem gebäude hat ruth stadelmann 23
jahre lang gearbeitet
dann wurde sie im rahmen einer
reorganisation ausgemacht
während das sehr lang durch das noch
verarbeiten
rang zu finden wie eine narbe durch
botschaft und schließlich sehe nicht
dass das so umgesetzt
da war viel zu passiv
[Musik]
wir werden aus mitarbeiterin im papier
management leider müssen wir ihnen
mitteilen
es sind in der zwischenzeit einige
bewerbungen eingegangen die dem
anforderungsprofil noch etwas näher
kommen im weiteren auswahlverfahren
nicht mehr berücksichtigen können sehr
geehrte frau stadelmann trotz dieser
guten qualifikation
wir sind überzeugt dass sie beide eine
position finden die ihren vorstellungen
in jeder beziehung entspricht viel
erfolg und alles gute
vielleicht kreuzen sich unsere wege bei
einer anderen gelegenheit mit
freundlichen grüßen aus klient fragte
ich muss mich andere muss es machen noch
ein parade bibliothek gestorben und
genau denn ich muss aus der sicht von
depressionen sich einen ruck geben einen
neuen weg finden keine einfache sache
[Musik]
das ist das nicht auch eine anja sie hat
mir körper anbietet
[Musik]
das ist natürlich die lange dauer
einfach resignation also nach all den
absagen hat an frischwasser den mut
verloren aber schon in ein paar monaten
wird sein leben eine unerwartete wendung
nehmen
arbeitslos abgestempelt aus gesteuert
immer mehr ältere menschen bleiben auf
dauer stellen los und sind auf
sozialhilfe angewiesen
in nur zehn jahren hat die zahl der
sozialhilfebezüger bei den über 50
jährigen um 40 prozent zugenommen
[Musik]
ein recyclinghof am stadtrand von zürich
raphael spielmann 49 rät sich liszt
lehrling einer der ältesten lernenden
der schweiz
und alles andere käme es vor dass bürger
ich bin absolut die lehre als
briefträger allerdings hat spielmann in
seiner jugend nicht abgeschlossen er
schlug sich lange mit gelegenheitsjobs
durch und war zeitweise arbeitslos
bis er an einer jobbörse für ältere
arbeitnehmer diesen beruf entdeckt weil
er noch keine abgeschlossene ausbildung
unterstützt in die arbeitslosenkasse mit
zuschüssen die den lehrlingslohn
aufbessern
eine riesen-chance für rafael spielmann
[Musik]
spielmann ist ein lehrling wie die
anderen
er genießt keine privilegien und muss
sich einordnung in die betriebsgeräusche
unterschrift und ober stift
klicken sie teilen wie ist er war nicht
gewollt
[Musik]
das fünfte der oper oder der
aber wie kommt es zu dieser schule wird
im laufe der dank der lehre eine arbeit
findet entlastet längerfristig die
arbeitslosenversicherung oder
sozialhilfe
deshalb hat der bund die lehre für
erwachsene zum förderschwerpunkt erklärt
auch in der pause ist spielmann vom
kollegen umgeben die halb so alt sind
wie er
als erstaunlich gut die italiener bieten
[Musik]
als junger mann hatte er keine
beruflichen ziele und bin auch die
scheidung alleinerziehende von spritze
und sogar kritik auf um nichts sorgen
sondern den fokus gerückt dass die
richtige bauen können das richtig gute
starter nach und jetzt wo das h2o fertig
sie schon ich gefunden so die studie
steht unter strom
mit dem lehrlingslohn den ausbildungs
zuschüssen und der halben iv kommt
spielt man auf 4000 franken im monat
ihm reicht das zum leben die iv wähler
bald aufgeben
er habe gelernt mit dem kaputten rücken
zu leben und zu arbeiten
gut qualifizierte arbeitslose wie alfred
wasser haben kein anrecht auf eine
bezahlte berufliche neuausrichtung
ihm bleibt nur die beharrliche
stellensuche in seinem fachgebiet und
endlich hat er gute nachrichten es für
weckt noch ein paar jahr bewerben und
bewerbern und noch immer absage hetze
von europa interessiert familie
bewerbung für meine person und bin ich
gerade worden
sonne zum vorstellungsgespräch scott um
linie firma das hightech-unternehmen
wurden geschäftsführer sucht und was für
mich eine sehr spannende aufgabe und
bieder und kann es kurz gespräche ins
kühlhaus und die zu artig ruf zweite
runde geht das erste
vorstellungsgespräch nach fast drei
jahren
da ich unbeschreiblich das ist einfach
passiert also so langsam hat sich ohne
schaden im rat glaubt das passiert so
fein ist das ist ungeschriebenes gefühl
und das ist was einfach an ihn noch
lange mit der flasche aufgemacht
ich halt möglichst fraglich halt wieder
absank
ja es ist krieg sie wollen nicht so sehr
wie arbeit und scheitern an anonymen
personalabteilungen die wahren gründe
für die absagen lassen sich nur erahnen
[Musik]
sie sind mit 20 jährige wo einst georg
ursel farbigkeit und dieselbe sprache es
geht um vorurteile komm mir gut
vorstellen dass es mit geht wo sich
keiner vorstellen mit meinen ältere
mitarbeitende moskau es werden aber wenn
wir die möglichkeit zum wählen nimmt man
die interview ist um abwehrmechanismen
um diskriminierung es ist schon bis zum
schluss wurde ältere mitarbeiter oft
unbeachtet weiter zu deiner lockt und
wie sich der finanzielle
das labor ist und was der 1000
gesellschaft hat man uns möglichkeit
nach neun jahren arbeitslosigkeit von
droht stadelmann im letzten sommer einen
minijob sie arbeitet auf abruf etwa zwei
halbe tage pro woche in diesem taucht
stadelmann ist erfahrene taucherin sie
kennt sich aus mit material und
produkten auch der arbeitslose ingenieur
andreas knuchel hat einen aushilfsjob
irgendwelche ursprüngliche tätigkeit
hier besitzen noch nicht gefangen und
dann natürlich blond ist langsam
entwickeln und bekannte zum mikrofon
headset das habe da hier die möglichkeit
nur die besten tag pro woche mit dem lkw
fahrer aus weiß macht die knödel in
jungen jahren
er ist gerne unterwegs auf der straße
der anreiz liegt nicht im geld roth
stadelmann hat es nach dem jobverlust
bei der post noch eine einjährige
handelsschule abgeschlossen
trotzdem verdient sie hier nur 20
franken pro stunde inclusive ferien und
feiertage pensum und verdienst sind so
gering dass ruth stadelmann auf dem
existenzminimum bleibt vom sozialamt
abzocker und das nicht so schön
ich mache andreas knüttel war früher als
manager unterwegs und fühlt sich
trotzdem wohl in dieser anderen welt
über qualifikation im minijob auch ein
thema bei ruth stadelmann ist ein
grundkurs natürlich der branchen der
vorarbeit und salat auch mit uns nun
verdammt ist dies allerdings nicht
gewinnt ist natürlich gut stadelmann hat
384 tauchgänge vom roten meer über die
malediven bis nach indonesien
sie musste ihr sandfang hobby aber
aufgeben als sie arbeitslos wurde so
günstig ist er gibt die fifa
unterfranken woche allerdings nicht auf
raphael spielmann rät sie christin
ausbildung ist unterwegs in die
berufsschule in einem abteil die zwei
schweizer interessiert
der 49 jährige gilt die lehre
entschlossener an als seine mitschüler
edition click once betriebe dass man
auch einfacher finanziell besser
ausstatten
[Musik]
pro woche steht im zweiten lehrjahr ein
schultag am guten werden heute die
sorten kommen die abschließen
das komplette gebiet der es heißt werden
auch zum thema metalle werden wir dort
fragen stellen sich die sozialisten klar
denkt richtig das weiße
zeitungsdruckpapier und das kkl einzige
weiße denke ich dass leister illustriert
den druck doch auch hier anzuschauen
also schreiben sie jetzt vielleicht ein
bisschen gesagt ihr recht auf musste
unbedeutende druck
es ist unbedruckte
14 worte haben gute noten durchschnitt
aber jetzt muss nach relativ stark
konzentriert zum teil kritisch ist mit
sachs ihre zustimmung ist ein aktiv ist
und da muss ich mir wirklich fokussieren
uns also sehr wohl gesagt und das in den
urlaub planten und bremen viele notizen
damit den euro - sind dass sie mitten im
leben steht kann natürlich vernünftige
machen im rat zu günstige sachen wo oder
euro gewiss sagte der 72 jährige
natürlich nicole ich schätze das sehr
sie könnte sich ein kreis mit das ist
für mich zum der wechselnden
verlängerten abend auf dem papier statt
durch seine darsteller mit einer farbe
was wichtig ist quelle damit gemeinsam
aus garten ist foto.de zur damit ich
dass wir im fotobereich nissan wollte
mein leben meisterin kurs bilden findet
das sehr gut und sie kommen auch will
das land 1 roth der vater durchs ganze
heft liegt damit aber nicht der brief
ist oklahoma kann ich die augen zumachen
der futtersuche das bild zur sache und
der macht stuck und dokumentiert
gedanken gefühle und also muss ich nicht
mehr wo sie täter der brüchigen griff
über und unterricht oder gar nicht nach
mit denen und für deine bildung hole ich
nachher wieder los
es ist der 23
dezember alfred wasser steckt noch immer
im auswahlverfahren für eine stelle als
geschäftsleitung
ja ich behaupte noch eine zweite sprache
ist mir wichtig dass also für mich ist
es gut sie ich würde die stelle gegeben
hatte und er hat mir versprochen dass
sie ja bisher an die die woche das war
es gehöre leider nie gehört ich weiß
noch nie wie syrien als fernkurs zählt
[Musik]
vergeblich versucht war sei das
unternehmen zu kontaktieren
die funkstille dauert bis ins neue jahr
[Musik]
ruth stadelmann kennt worten empfangen
allein in der wohnung
sie hat es nicht mehr ausgehalten ihr
ausweg freiwilligenarbeit die zwitscher
bar in luzern ist ein begegnungsort der
reformierten und katholischen kirche
hier hat tod stadelmann eine neue heimat
gefunden
nach jahren der isolation und depression
und das ist für mich sehr dass ich
möchte in der regel arbeitet sie einen
halben tag pro woche im café neben ihrem
neuen bezahlten manager und auch laden
und das erscheint schon elizabeth und
ich denke ich kann mich als lieferant
positiv
[Musik]
es ist januar alfred haase hat eine
absage bekommen für die stelle die er
sich so sehr wünscht
wieder von baden mit trotzdem ist das
für mich ist kurz und nicht sie ich habe
nicht wie der eigentlich mit der
bissigen auseinandersetzen
ich habe mir eine wohnung dass wir
würdig vertreten
das ist für mich ganz wichtig sie
eigentlich ohne ihn wohl nicht die messe
und immer schön wenn ich liebe dich
endlich sind und und das wo natürlich
der tanz cohen nach die mieten
im zürcher hauptbahnhof treffen wir
andreas knoche er hat es geschafft von
einem tag auf den anderen fand er eine
neue stelle pensum 40 prozent
das ist bequem auch die jobs selber ist
wahnsinnig spannend aber natürlich jetzt
noch das hat der lage der ausländer
knuchel ist für eine teamsitzung
angereist er arbeitet neu für skills
onyx ein start-up-unternehmen dass die
schweizer berufslehre ins ausland
exportieren
seine aufgabe ist es partner firmen im
in und ausland zu finden
die qualifiziertes personal brauchen und
darum in die berufsschulen investieren
der neue chef schenkt knüppel vertrauen
zueinander flexibilität und eine große
vorteile
darum ist eher fokussiert und eigentlich
sogar oder sogar flexibler ja immer das
nicht installiert aber nicht eigentlich
das ist es auch schwieriger bezwingender
voi diese konstellation in der box oder
mir passiert noch nie jemand macht
speziell und und das ist gut denn da ich
die berufserfahrungen doch sehr gut die
erfahrung aus der wirtschaft und das
findet hat diese arbeit mit hilfe
gefunden
er gelangte an den verband avenir 50plus
der türen öffnen will in eine
verschlossene arbeitswelt selber
langzeitarbeitslos gründete heavy user
wenn ihr 50plus und bietet anderen
betroffenen coaching rat und tat
arbeitslose wie andreas knoche sind auf
beziehungen angewiesen
das ist für sehr qualifiziert die
forschen immer möglich mit ruhm
deshalb spielt hardy hughes einzelne
fälle direkt im arbeitgeberverband zu
präsident valentin vogt übernimmt als
mentor danken aber der bedeutung der
besucht und kann ich finde dich anhalt
verdient mache ich das auch gehören und
ich die einzelnen mit der einzelne räte
dann geht mir das selbst endlich
es ist einfach so dass natürlich die mit
dem auto
ja sicher wäre sicher
sie beschrieben sich irgendwo soziale
medien verbreiten und dann hob er die
oper dass das massenphänomen ist die
schweiz das ist es nicht es wird aber
unter dein lied wo kastel findet im
ratssaal wo es wirklich schwierig ist
und dieser name ist lernen vermittelt
einige blüht das hat einfach ein küster
jahr zur folge
dabei genau arbeitsmarkt werden
zurückfinden das ist einfach so ich
glaube dass die schatten voraus
gesellschaft
[Musik]
andreas kröll hat mit hilfe von valentin
vogt wieder einen job gefunden
bald könne auf sechzig prozent
aufstocken mit aussicht auf mehr
entspannen das ist ganz neu
internationalen archiv-foto aber von
mein arbeitsgebiet ist das ganz anders
[Musik]
natürlich massiv durch
das war sehr gut das mittelbare und
unmittelbare hilflos trend ist dass man
an die momente der zufälligkeit aber es
ist natürlich auch pensionskassen euro
entsprechend länder die löcher in der
vorsorge sind nicht mehr zu stopfen
er wird auch nach der pensionierung noch
an den folgen der arbeitslosigkeit
leiden
[Musik]
eine studie zeigt dass ältere menschen
oft kompromisse eingehen müssen um den
beruflichen anschluss zu halten
erhebliche lohneinbußen tiefere
funktionen mehrere teilzeitjobs
gleichzeitig oder unregelmäßige
arbeitszeiten
[Musik]
ein mittwochvormittag in bruck seit
knapp einem jahr besucht an fred weiser
hier eine selbsthilfegruppe für ältere
arbeitslose als betroffener hat freddy
siegenthaler die runde vor zwölf jahren
ins leben gerufen
die kirchgemeinde unterstützt ihn und
stellt den raum zur verfügung und tat
wird klar warum alfred wasser so strahlt
er hat sich verliebt und sein
privatleben umgekrempelt relativ kurz
entschlossen heftige sache spontan
entscheiden wie mit 21 jährige auch
danach wie sich im nachhinein schreiben
werden müssen also jungen kaufen
[Musik]
im kz ich schon noch keine stellen wie
wäre es mit dem enthusiasmus und das so
ich mache und nur klassische auf dem
klassischen stelle permanent absage
das ist nicht verwunderlich wenn der
ganze hof vorstellen lose gekauft jeder
ist prozent verständigung ausgeschrieben
sind schmeiße also müssen sie also über
die kurze anleitung wurde stellt für die
knaben und da haben wir gefunden haben
wir zudem oder sind nur auf irgendeine
art macht und autorität der öffentlichen
arbeitsmarkt ich denke auf der light
kann sich eh nicht verloren sondern
einzig tragen innovationskraft
kreativität der besuch der
selbsthilfegruppe ist für viele ältere
arbeitslose ein erster schritt zurück
ins leben
auch für alfred wasser
feierabend bei raffael spielmann
[Musik]
tochter jenny ist in thal assistentin
und hat die lehre schon abgeschlossen
im gegensatz zu ihrem vater jenny lieb
zu hause und habe den beruflichen
aufbruch des vaters miterlebt richtige
ausbildung hat bezüglich stolz auf das
neue lied macht die sie im alltag nehmen
dass man sowohl ein streber main sogar
die note linie htv beim schießen auf die
beduftung von der konstruktion zu gast
war
du weißt genau thomas sie haben heute
ein gutes händchen für praktisches
arbeiten
das praktische arbeiten hat spielt man
heute schon hinter sich
es war die hausaufgaben wirklich
semester für semester machen
gut jedes semester gute abschlüsse und
vanille sowie sitzen so wenn sie so
weiter läuft wie kurt abschlüsse wie
diplom machen weil ich 60 sei nicht nur
das - und damit dem monitor betriebe der
aufwand hat das panik als noch wichtiger
die jugendlichen
[Musik]
stadelmann genießt ein kleines ritual
wenn ich dir schlachte absage alle
zusammen
[Musik]
dann bin ich zu je 80 noch gar nicht da
war und dann kann ich vom in
pensionskassen geld und bleibe und dass
es so nicht mehr details können auf
australien die tür einfach so mit der
gruppe günstige geht so und tauchen und
lila
[Musik]
alfred wasser trifft im neuen daheim ein
im haus seiner freundin in erlinsbach
[Musik]
wunderbar
das habe ich auch susan frei ist seit
langem arbeitslos war sagt sie über eine
gemeinsame bekannte aus der
selbsthilfegruppe kennengelernt
es hat gefunkt das ist eben schwieriger
wurde es am wochenende gegangen ist habe
ich sogar jetzt und jetzt muss ich
wieder und irgendwie ich bin mir sicher
dass du freunde zu mir passt zu mir
passen zusammen
du brauchst dich zu mir ja das ist wie
tag und nacht
also ja ich meine mit mit mit so ein
toller mensch zählt das erlebnis für
sich und das ist durchaus angepasst also
welches kind und jetzt das natürlich
auch in wohnsituation in ihre dörfer wo
ich würde mich einfach wohl nicht gerade
bei der öffentlichkeit bin wenn ich zum
ausgangshafen oder wieder die
privatsphäre
das ist natürlich wunderbar
ja mir gewaltig während beide freute
auch große mio
eine tolle woche endet sie mit dem
suzuki motor erste große schritt
überrascht als ich endlich den mut
gefasst hat sondern es erhebt hilfe
gruppen finden und co
das neue lied kurz netzwerk gute
diskussionen oder mit der neue idee
ausgabe 31 wien wichtigsten traum wo
jetzt möchte ich eigentlich wirklich der
hoffentlich auch bald mal stellt wende
bin guten mutes passt das bringt
[Musik]